this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice dr john deloney ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the ever popular dr
john deloney podcast which is exploding
across america right now and uh when he
talks about mental health and boundaries
and relationships and crazy people in
your family and all that kind of stuff
and uh everybody's got em baby so he's
here to help with your life and i'm here
to help with your money and we will just
get in each other's business and have
fun talking about you folk right in
front of you phone number's at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five so the people in the
lobby are already pointing at each other
about who's when you said every family's
got em they all looked at it they all
started pointing at each other he looks
relatively handsome he looks like a nice
guy but i think she's talking about his
family no i think she's talking about
him
man i can't tell through the glass there
let him have it it's just wow merciless
already out there in the in the studio
audience that's right open phones here
jump in you can get on again dr john
deloney here triple eight eight two five
five two two five tom's in san antonio
hey tom what's up
well hi dave it's pleasure to talk with
you i just had a question i'm probably
three years away from retirement and i
just wanted to know what you would think
would be a reasonable
percentage of my principle to withdraw
from my retirement accounts once i do
reach
retirement why are you withdrawing
principle
well i'm sorry we
probably i'd phrase that wrong but how
much could i expect to draw down from
those accounts okay do you think this
will support me well i mean there's some
primitive math you can do and that'll
probably get you close uh close enough
to where it's the math i'm going to do
on mine
um so the the inflation rate for the
last 78 years or so not counting the
last four months uh has been about 4.2
percent and that included jimmy carter
when it was 12 so this four point this
current six percent is going to get
absorbed into that so you can figure a
four four and a half percent
inflation rate
okay
so if your money your your nest egg is
not at least growing that much it's not
breaking even it's deteriorating and
purchasing power understand
yes because a million dollars won't buy
what a million dollars would 20 years
ago
same thing right that kind of thing and
you know if you retire you got 20 years
or 30 years or 40 years this money's got
to last so it won't buy the same loaf of
bread 30 years later for sure so you
want to at least break even so i try to
not draw down try to leave at least four
percent of the growth in the account
at least
and so that it breaks even with
inflation and so if you're making
10 then you could draw down five or six
pretty safely right
if it you know and on average and so
and here's the other thing if let's say
one year you made but you set it up on a
six percent draw down at ten okay which
is a real simple math with what we're
talking about right here um
and uh uh one year the thing didn't make
10 it made eight
and so you kind of cut into some of your
inflation or principal money a little
bit well that's okay because another
year it'll make 12
and you're still only pulling out six
and you'll put the two back
so the variance in the market will
if you get if you have a tight formula
or work itself out over a decade
you know and so you're not going to chew
up the principle doing that now that's
assuming you actually make that now if
you're continually not making enough
year in and year out well that's the
investment setup and so forth so how
much money you got
uh right now it's uh probably five point
three
million in investable assets okay you're
not getting me you got a lead with that
brother come on man i should have asked
earlier i'm sorry well way to go tom
that's awesome man touchdown
it doesn't matter take out what you want
three percent four percent i wasn't sure
what yeah i mean you you can live a
great dadgum life pulling off three four
five percent off of that and never as
long as it's invested in good mutual
funds or something like that where
you're making if you're making that 10
mark and you're pulling off 345 you're
gonna be just fine i mean and you
probably have some of it doing better
than that some of it not doing that good
but
okay uh but way to go did you do that
oh just working and you know
when i started working i just started
putting away as much into my retirement
account as the law would allowed because
the law would allow so you didn't make
it all like investing in beanie babies
or bitcoin oh heck no no okay all right
you didn't get rich with nothing down
real estate
no okay so you just steadily invested
you're boring i love you yeah well we we
barred for our first house
the house we're on our fifth house now
but that's the only the only one that we
borrowed on was our first house so we
just paid cash for the others what was
your what was your income through the
years
well
about 250. okay so you make good money
but you just chunked it you lived well
and chunked a bunch of it and investing
and there you go now you're worth five
million dollars how old are you right um
64. way to go man way to go i'm so proud
of you none of the kids on the internet
are gonna like this guy at all
no he's he's like
he's like the the proper millionaire i
mean this is the way people become
millionaires this way not all that other
crap yeah like that's why they're all
kids on the internet for a long time and
then ta-da
yeah it didn't hit the lottery didn't
make his money on beanie babies
it's like driving down the road and
there's that sign on the side of the
road that says call me and ask me how i
lost weight and you call them and they
say diet and exercise ta-da
oh oh yeah that'd be that'd be five
bucks yeah
man josh is in austin texas hey josh how
are you
i'm pretty good dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
hey dave i had a question so me and my
wife together make about a little bit
over a hundred grand a year
we have
um which is about 17
18 and then a boat i just bought
foolishly not too long during the
pandemic and that's about 17. so
my main question was that's that's our
debt and then she has about 10 000 in
student debt um that's all the debt that
we have
um that's all one main question i don't
think that's the right phrase it's like
oh my god i'm so scared because i'm so
deeply in debt is the right phrase
well i mean it could be a lot worse i've
seen some of my friends that i think
worse well it could be worse you could
be in congress but i mean it still sucks
yeah exactly and by the way hey hold on
hold on that student loan debt is your
debt too brother it's not just no i know
and that's once we got married i'm like
it's mine too so all right guys yes sir
so um my main question was so we both
have credit cards and
we
use them every month and we pay them off
in full every single month
um them is to
correct collect the points and not the
points with the cash back i mean those
that we're going to pay and then
expenses we're going to use every month
of course you're the guy with 34 000 in
car and boat debt and a student loan
debt that's been around so long
it looks like a pet in your bedroom of
course you use credit cards
you fit the profile exactly and you're
foolish enough to actually believe it's
working for you
no and i don't i don't think my question
is you start telling me about the
airline points
no i don't i don't use airline points
it's all cash back and i run it into my
son saving whenever i cash it out but i
guess my question is
um i have about thirty thousand in stock
and then um
i have my 401k which i can't pull until
i'm retired
but um
would you suggest i just take it let me
ask you something let me ask you
something
do you really want to work on this
if i tell you what to do will you go do
it
yes sir all right you hold on to the
break and i'll help you this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
dr john deloney my co-host today ramsey
personality you can hear the dr john
deloney show new episodes every monday
wednesday and friday on youtube and
anywhere you listen to great podcasts
and uh tune in there all right we're
talking with josh josh is in austin
texas josh has 17 000 on a boat he just
bought 17 000 on a car 10 000 on his
wife's student loans and he's asking
about using credit cards as long as he
pays him off every month and gets the
points that he puts into his son's
savings is that a fair summary of what
you told me sir
yes sir okay how old are you sir
i'm 30. oh and you make 100k that's the
other thing yeah then all with my wife
and me yeah household household income
yeah okay listen okay and you've not
been listening to us for very long
correct
no sir i decided my dad told me about
y'all about a year ago okay all right so
um
instead of giving you the uh snarky
smart i like answer then i'm gonna uh be
uh
gentle because i was assuming when you
were asking all of that a while ago that
you knew a lot more about what we teach
than you do so let me back up a little
bit and tell you this okay
we've done
coaching with families teaching them how
to handle money for 30 years
tens of millions of families
and we just finished and published in a
book called everyday millionaires
a uh the largest study of millionaires
ever done in north america studying
how they did that
okay because the subject really is
when i'm talking to 30 year old josh who
makes 100 000 household income what is
the shortest distance between where you
are now
and wealth
how fast can you get there what's the
fastest way and the most
the highest probability of getting there
without being crazy and taking a bunch
of risk and being rash and unwise what
is the way that most millionaires become
millionaires and if i can get you to do
that
then you have the highest chance of
prospering and that's my goal here okay
yes sir okay now given all of that the
first thing that we discovered many many
years ago and we've taught successfully
and it's led a lot of people to become
millionaires is your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income
and when you give your income to someone
else in the form of payments
debt you slow down
inhibit
the ability to grow wealth
because if you add up for instance the
average car payment in america right now
josh is a little over 500 a month
if you invest 500 a month from 30 to 65
in a decent growth stock mutual fund
it's about 5 million
hope you like the car because that's
what that car payment cost you
if you keep a car payment your whole
life like most people do
but they could have had five million
dollars instead they kept a car payment
their whole life because the fact that
they had a car payment was normalized by
our culture and they weren't feeling any
pain from having the car payment kind of
like you
yes sir it's not bothering you at all it
was bothering me more that you had a car
payment a while ago than you
you follow me
yes sir and i used to have a truck so i
had a checkpoint i'd say probably a
couple of months ago that i completely
paid off that's good and i'm sure you're
heading in the right direction and then
you went and bought a boat to replace
the payment
yeah pretty much but i just just go with
your car and then
pay off the boat so here's the thing
if you if you're gonna commit to a
millionaire plan
the shortest distance is two things
one is to avoid debt
and so you don't go buy boats unless you
can pay cash for them and you don't go
buy cars unless you can pay cash for
them and you take the debt that you have
and you work really really hard to get
rid of it as soon as possible
okay
um and then
over to your other question
uh in all of the millionaires that we
studied and we studied over 10 000 of
them
not a single one
said they made their money
by efficient use of credit cards and
collecting points and marilyn miles
not one
that's not a millionaire game
that's a middle class falling for bank
of america's bull crap game
discovers bullcrap game where you make
them rich
and so the millionaires some of them do
what you're doing
and some of them use a debit card and
just pay for things because they don't
want to take the chance of rationalizing
their way into credit card debt which
you're about a half an eyebrow length
from doing
you're gonna accidentally fall into
credit card debt one of these days doing
what you're doing because you're
undisciplined in handling your money
right now and i'm not picking on you i'm
just observing
okay now you can do what you want to do
you're a successful young man you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year you have
all the toys and all the things out in
your driveway that make people think
you're making it but you're broke
you have forty four thousand dollars in
debt you make a hundred thousand
and
you're calling me about how to
efficiently use a credit card to give
your son four dollars
in points
into his little account
and so you know you need to back up and
say am i willing to change some of that
am i willing to go another direction
okay and um
so i'm i'm hitting you pretty hard here
but the biggest enemy
of uh
of success is not failure
it's mediocrity because you get
comfortable in the middle ground of
average and you'll be average you right
now statistically are a normal american
and normal sucks
work your whole life end up with nothing
and it all went to freaking banks
in the form of payments and none of it
went into your mutual funds now you got
some going in your 401k that's good so i
would take your 30 000 in stock i would
cash it out and i would pay off your
wife's student loan in your car and i'd
sell your boat
today now
and now you're debt-free and now you can
start building some wealth and you can
buy you another boat later i've got
boats i love boats i got two master
crafts sitting on the lift waiting on me
to head down there this weekend to the
lake house i love boats i'm not against
you having a boat i'm against your boat
having you and you paid as much for the
stinking boat as you did your wife's car
dude
really
it hit me
i think you and i have talked about this
privately they hit me a few years ago
these the credit card company or the
airline company's not my friend
like they're not hooking me up
and it's it's like
hey come here behind the buildings
i got something for you hey buy 10 of
these things bro i'll just give you 10
bucks that's that's what hap what's
happening they're investing
in the in the potential that i'm gonna
fall down they have looked at my debt
profile they've looked at the way i
spend money what i buy i buy it on they
know more about your behaviors than
yours that's exactly right and so they
are gambling on hey we're just going to
keep getting they're not even gambling
yeah that's true it's an actuary table
they know they're making an investment
that i'm going to fall down and they're
just waiting 10 bucks a month 20 bucks a
month 20 bucks a month 20 bucks a month
ah there it is his transmission fell out
and he just put 10 grand on this credit
card
they know what the probability of you
being in credit card debt is better than
i know or you know 100 and you're you're
you're making a hundred grand you're
living in that zip code they know what
bottled water you drink dude that's
exactly right i mean the marketing
analysis on the data on you uh
especially these days with google where
they're just completely
they follow you they're they're they're
completely going through your underwear
drawer every day they know everything
about you yeah and the nightstand i mean
they're going through everything
everything and and you've told them
everything voluntarily and so now they
can track you down and pin your ears to
the wall i know because we do it we buy
very targeted google ads very targeted
facebook ads to get you people to plug
into this stuff right and so i and we're
not nearly as sophisticated well you're
the most altruistic businessman i know
and so yeah anything off of that but
here's the thing they're giving you that
flight for a reason yeah they're not
your friend yeah and by the way it's
it's never the good flight yeah yeah so
jupiter has to be aligned with mars you
can only travel on the age of aquarius
so um
under you know
under the red moon or the blue moon
which is it you know it's unbelievable
yeah so
try lining up those dadgum air but the
the point is
study what people who are wealthy have
done not what theory is
a lot of broke people and i i grew up
this way we sit around and talk i sit
around the campfire
sit around
you know everybody's playing uh spades
and sitting there and on friday night
and all the neighbors are sitting around
you're playing pinocchio or whatever our
parents played you know cards and and
they're all talking about they've all
got theories about how rich people
really are and all of them are wrong
every one of them if their theories were
right they wouldn't be sitting at that
table
anymore that's right because they would
have understood that yeah but so your
broke friends
all got all these financial principles
in theories
and so hey cash all right josh if you're
ready to change you tell kelly if you're
not don't it's okay if you're just mad
at me it's alright too
because i'm here i've got a gift to that
if you tell kelly i'll sign you up for
ramsey plus and put you through our
class and teach you how to do this and i
won't charge you a dime
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
where we give you common sense for your
dollars and cents and your life
ed and liz are with us in grand rapids
michigan hey guys how are you
great how are you better than i deserve
it says on my screen you're debt free
congratulations how much did you pay off
335 000.
how long did that take
nine and a half years all right and your
range of income during that time
uh 96 to 144 000 good for you what do
you guys do for a living i'm a teacher
and i'm a physician assistant all right
well i'm guessing since it took nine and
a half years and it was a lot of money
maybe you paid off the house
we sure did
[Music]
talking to weird people
way to go you guys how old are you guys
34. and you have a paid for house
that's ridiculous
what's this house worth
about 350.
[Laughter]
and you're 34 freaking years old wow
that's so awesome man i'm so proud of
y'all well done well done touchdown all
right tell us your story what happened
nine and a half years ago that put you
on this ramsey type journey you're on
sure so after we got married we kind of
wandered in and out of debt with home
improvement loans car loans we were
still paying off
student loans
using credit cards and you know we
thought that we were doing well because
we would pay it off before the interest
started or you know immediately after
and you know we were just kind of
playing with fire
because all it would have taken was one
loss of a job or a big expense and you
know things would have would have gotten
ugly real quick
so we really didn't start the kind of
gazelle intense until we found out that
we couldn't have biological children and
we realized we'd need about
25 000
for
each adoption and we were planning on
doing it twice
and we didn't want to go into more debt
with our children so we did fundraising
and we did extra work to cash flow both
of those
during while we were paying everything
else off and wow around that time we
found you guys and we paid off the rest
of our debt and mortgage in a short
period so it had taken us seven years to
pay off you know all those things in our
75 000 mortgage
and then two and a half years to pay off
the other 75 of our mortgage and we did
the last 46 in the past nine months
yeah when you can see the finish line
you sprinted we sure did
that's incredible i know
most of my friends in my life can't do a
workout program for nine days how did
y'all stay on this for nine years
um so we started
i guess just
before we even knew about the the kids
it was well let's just pay off our our
house and we threw extra money at that
for a long time
um
having that kind of be our ultimate goal
to get that paid off
um
and then you know when we kind of saw
well we started watching the
amortization schedule we're like hey we
could have this paid off by this time
and then it was like well maybe we could
have it paid off by this time
you know we we just kind of watched that
and it really motivated us to see we
were so close let's let's keep going
um
my motto was debt free by 33.
okay and you made it huh or real close
all right so um you've been married what
ten years
yeah yep and you and you uh you found us
how long ago
about four and a half five years ago
okay so that you were already kind of on
the general path and all we did was just
help you tighten it up is that how this
works
um yeah i mean i think we were still
like i said using credit cards and
things kind of prior to you guys um i
think you know we were kind of playing
with with fire we were doing okay but we
weren't in in good habits i would yeah
and how did you find us radio or
financial peace university or what
yeah through podcasts and the radio show
i was listening to okay cool cool how
much is in your retirement
right around 100.
okay so your net worth's about a half a
million already and you're 34.
so that means you're probably going to
be millionaires by 40 or so
we're hoping
that's the track you're on you'll be
baby step millionaires you've done this
stuff the way we teach i'm so proud of
y'all
thank you what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is you're 34
with a paid for house you actually know
well i think uh it's just having the
budget and we have meetings weekly still
it used to take a lot longer and
when we look back at our first couple of
budgets that we did once we found you
guys
they were really ugly and messy
and now it's just kind of habit and the
budget is so important and
i also teach your foundations class at
the middle school that i teach at thank
you
and yeah
and uh the one episode where rachel
talks about driving in reverse that's
what we were doing with our credit cards
we were using them um you know we were
driving reverse and always looking at
what we had paid now that we use just
the debit cards or just cash now we can
actually see forward and it's a lot
easier
powerful very cool
very cool yeah you got to be careful
what you teach because you'll learn it
right
yeah nobody holds you accountable like a
room full of middle schoolers either
right right yeah they're savages man
yeah so teach you really do this or not
huh
tell the truth what's it really like
yeah they're they are savages 13 year
old savages
yeah
wow way to go you guys i'm so proud of
you what are they what are the kiddos
names and ages
so eddie is four and elliot is two joy
of your life huh
yes yes it was it was a long road to uh
to adopt them but it was it's a
beautiful gift from god and we um we are
just so so blessed
yeah you received a beautiful gift and
you gave one too yeah fabulous so so
beautifully well done well done well
done yeah their pictures are showing up
on the youtube feed and we're seeing
them here they're great looking young
guys look like full-on boys i love it
oh yeah they are they are 100 boys yeah
i love it
well congratulations you guys we're so
proud of you we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story as you're on your way to
baby being baby steps millionaires and
of course we'll give you another copy of
the total money makeover as well
so you can give it away to someone and
get them started on their journey
because that's the as you know that's
the roadmap the blueprint on how to get
where you are at 34 years old you guys
are so impressive all right count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
three
two
one
[Music]
i love it
so you know what my problem is
one i have talked to ed and liz
70 000 times
in 30 years
so when josh calls it just wells up in
you and i know he should be them instead
of him yeah i i i i'm already over there
and i have to stop a minute and try to
get josh to go with me yes because i
already go over there and i'm like i'm
just going to kill you that's right i'm
just going to kill you right here on the
radio in front of 22 million people and
it's it that's not fair to poor josh
because he's new to the game he's just
figuring it out he's just getting there
and it wasn't fair to him to just take
his head off and i didn't so but here
here's where
they're 34 he's 30.
they make about the same amount they
make about the same amount of money and
their house is paid off
yeah and four years later if he sells
the boat he does this stuff that's why i
and the problem is and you've done this
in counseling as well sometimes you want
it for them more than they want it and
you can yeah i can never get myself in
that trap because then i start wearing
other people's garbage and you can't do
that no i'm not wearing his garbage no
i'm not you i'm just saying get him see
it i can see he can do it for him i know
he can do it i mean i know because
he's got more data stored in my brain on
this subject than any human walk in the
planet he's taking these five dollar
checks from discover and thinking you
know what i'm really hooking my son up
for the future
don't get me started uh what if you
didn't have a house payment you give
that to that little boy right
or instead of giving him a uh yeah or
how about adding a huh
our 50 000 to the equation for adoption
while you're on the journey yeah and go
ahead and knock it all out baby exactly
let's just just put that in there too
while we're at it
ding ding see the point being folk
you can do this but you know what the
number one barrier of you doing this is
is you believing you can do it that's
right
number one and i can't make you believe
i can teach you i can show you i can
be funny i can yell at you but i can't
make you do it but there they are the
two bookends
right here in one hour one hour man this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
[Music]
if you'd like to participate in the dr
john dolone show you can email him at
ask john
ramseysolutions.com ask john
ramseysolutions.com or even call and
leave a voicemail and he'll get you on
the phone make you part of the program
it's a call-in show at 844-693-3291
here at ramsey solutions we want to
transform so many lives that disruption
spreads like wildfire across our country
imagine a world where it's weird to have
a student loan where
everybody pays cash for cars where a
credit card is the cigarette of the
financial world
it's no longer cool
imagine that level of disruption imagine
a world where people have learned from
dr john delony how to do their
relationships at a whole different level
from ken coleman how to run their
careers at a whole different level if
you want to join us on a crusade that's
transforming people
we're currently on the hunt for software
engineers
ruby on rails java c-sharp front-end
technologies if you're a ux designer seo
content marketing specialist we're
hiring about 300 people this year and
150 of them are tech
and uh so if you want to actually do
programming on something that matters
and where you get to see the results of
it
and by the way work only 40 hours a week
we don't work 80 hours a week here even
our coders don't work 80 hours a week
here even our platform guys don't work
80 hours a week here we go home to our
families in the evenings we're not
confused about who's in charge here
if you want to find out about the
available jobs text work to 33789
work to 33789
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
even if you mismeasure or you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your window
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey to get
the best possible deal all right today's
question comes from steven in ohio he
says i'm 29 and i work as a security
guard earning a little over 19 thousand
dollars this year
i live with my girlfriend and her two
sons and i'm barely keeping my little
family afloat
i'm stressed out because i can't get my
girlfriend to be financially responsible
even though she says she's on board she
voluntarily cuts her work hours leaving
the bills to me the only thing she helps
with is groceries because she receives
food stamps
how do i get her motivated about
budgeting and saving if she won't get on
board should i give up the last two
years with her and these boys
who man um
brother you are being taken advantage of
and you are financially supporting
somebody who's not invested in you or
this family or their safety and security
and i know that's hard to hear because
it clearly you're you love this person
and you love her kids and you even refer
to them as your little family right now
they're not um you are a outside
participant who has been duped into
paying for everything for everybody
um
this is hard you can't get her motivated
about budgeting and saving you've tried
she's not interested in that
she's interested in you paying for her
life and her boy's life while she does
whatever she wants to do
um
this is heartbreaking dave
can you um
can someone like her
uh is there a percentage chance she's
brought around with the right scenario
or is this just walking papers
um
i always default to henry cloud's famous
saying which is she needs some problems
she needs some challenges um right now
she's got a guy who's not making hardly
any i mean he's yeah was he just barely
over the poverty line here yeah um he's
struggling security guard work is hard
and it's late nights and it's exhausting
all that and um
i think she needs
and i hate to say that because she's
clearly had a hard time she's got two
boys she's got a tough road ahead but um
i think she's got to recognize oh this
just doesn't actually happen this way
and i'm here here's my guess dave and
this isn't fair because again these
things you never know the full story
here if stephen left there would be
somebody new in relatively short order i
think
and i think stephen i just read through
the lines here man it looks like he is
trying and working and thinking and
dreaming
um
but it's got to be heartbreaking yeah so
i mean
a best case scenario is he
uh
says okay
the number one thing that breaks up
families and breaks up marriages is
money and money fights money problems
and money fights
and you're having one and you're not
even married
and so um
to see a future of this getting better
without a an abrupt
turn
a u-turn in the behaviors
um
then
then then yeah then you're just kidding
yourself
because let me just tell you if you
gonna make a hundred thousand this
doesn't get better it gets worse it
magnifies worse it magnifies it and uh
reading this thing he cares more about
this little family than she does well
then
then
she doesn't know how to she's one of the
tools that's right she know the tools so
i you know if um
i always want to give somebody a shot
always you know so it wouldn't sound
like i'm just done
because you're just too stupid to help
and i'm walking out of here okay so
instead i i
but but i'd also don't want you to live
in denial and four years from now still
be waiting on our change because that's
bs okay but i would say something along
the lines of hey number one thing breaks
up families and we're not even really
technically a family yet there's money
fights and money problems and we got
those and so in order for me to stay
here and in order for us to move towards
marriage and move towards life and me
move into my new career and double my
income
we're going to have to be on the same
page about this and that's going to be
we're going to get this family balanced
and off of food stamps
you're going to be working
and i'm going to be working and we're
going to be living on less than we make
and we're going to be responsible if you
don't want to participate in that then
that's you're saying
no i don't want you here that's right
and that's the price of me being here is
that we're going to be grown-ups and
that's steven looking in the mirror and
saying what do i need like what what
what do i need in my life that's going
to help me see my reflection with
dignity and respect and value and right
now he's trying to get that by solving
everyone else's problems he can't right
so that's him looking in the mirror
saying
the toxic
horrible old joke is if you're going to
marry a woman who loves spending money
you better enjoy making it mm-hmm okay
and that's you know that's obviously a
you know a
backward horrible joke but especially in
this setting
but uh but i mean you know if you marry
a princess she ain't gonna grow up to be
anything but a princess right if you
marry a guy who's lazy he's not gonna
grow up anything anything but lazy if
you marry these things and so unless
they got to be a change unless they go
they have a moment and they have this
epiphany and sometimes that's an
intervention of sorts yeah that you're
saying it's an ultimatum you're saying
i don't see this going
good going anywhere good 10 years from
today so i'm not going to do this
anymore based on
momentary feelings right
now if if we can do these things then i
can change my mind about it going
forward and i think we can go forward
but uh even as much as i love you i
can't participate in this anymore and
that's what henry cloud our friend again
says is a necessary ending it's when you
lose hope that the future is going to
get better that's right and i i and i
think it's important to call this out he
says here at the end if she won't get on
board should i give up the last two
years yes dave we see this in investing
and we see this in relationships this
sunk cost idea yeah and i talk to so
many people in the relationships that
say well i've got seven years in and
yeah he's verbally abusive but i've
already got seven years
what two years are you giving up here
these three years kind of sucked they
sound like they've been really brutal on
you right yeah so yeah bring me yeah
thank you may i have another that's
right no thank you i think i'll pass on
that so i get the investment man but yes
sorry it's not it's not an investment
it's um
it's when you didn't deal with this
earlier is all that two years was
you you did you should have dealt with
yeah you moved in with her you did all
this stuff in the wrong order and you
set yourself up for failure and that's
that's where you're setting today
my heart's broken for both of them man
yeah i i
it would be very cool if they could sit
down
with a marriage counselor with a pastor
and someone guide them through getting
on a long-term vision
for their end quotes little family
that's right so we're going to get
married we're going to both work we're
going to both be responsible we're going
to bring in more income we're going to
model these little boys get this thing
off the poverty line so these little
boys
can can have a better life and we're
going to be grown-ups because what we're
dealing with here is he's got three kids
that's exactly right
making 19 000 a year
man or woman is not a man or woman thing
it's a child thing adults devise a plan
and follow it
children do what feels good
dr john deloney good hour good hour to
james childs our producer kelly daniel
i'm dave ramsey your host we'll be back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money and uh his show the
dr john dolone shows where we talk about
he talks about relationships talks about
mental health anxiety depression all
kinds of wild stuff and it's with
regular real people they're not all
crazy
and it's uh it's downright informative
entertaining and a lot of times folks
dealing with trauma all kinds of things
so monday wednesday and friday you can
find it on youtube or anywhere great
podcasts are listened to
so wherever you tune in for podcasts you
can catch him there and be sure you do
meantime he's right here open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five jenna is with us in saint paul hi
jenna how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
well about five years ago i took
financial peace and was following the
baby steps and made it through the first
three baby steps and really enjoyed it
and
just purchased about a year and a half
ago my first my first home good for you
and
yeah it's half paid off so it was really
exciting wow um but
yeah it was it was really fun um but now
i'm really nervous about
um
retirement and i haven't um
thought about baby step number four that
whole investing piece makes me really
nervous about should i pay off the house
first should i start investing
i'd rather pay off the house
but
[Music]
so let me get this straight you learned
a financial process
called the baby steps and you've used
them
very very successfully to get where you
are
and you've done very well by the way
and now you're wondering if they really
work
now
[Music]
what happens after baby step three jenna
baby step four
baby step four is put 15
of your household income into retirement
if the first three baby steps work kiddo
the last three are going to work and
they're going to lead you right to
wealth
yeah i think the thing that's really
intimidating about baby step number four
is just feeling like i don't understand
the process
as much as when i had a number i was
like oh i'm saving for a down payment i
feel like i'm making progress good you
know but you've never bought a house
before right
no was closing that house not a little
bit intimidating and scary it was
scared me to death yeah first time my
clothes don't want scared to pee out of
me
so um i understand okay
i get it but that was brand new thing
and you went and learned how to do that
because it was worth learning how to do
and so the same thing's true with
investing
when you get off you click smart vester
at ramsey solutions you sit down with
one you remember they have the heart of
a teacher why do they need the heart of
a teacher because jenna needs to learn
because when she learns she's not scared
anymore
sure does that make sense
it makes sense first time you drove a
car you sucked at it
me too
i threw gravel all over the garage door
because i didn't know you didn't just
step all the way down on the accelerator
i thought you just hit it
you know and so that you you learn
everything you do is a learning process
and now i drive a car and don't think
about it most people don't think at all
and then it shows in the way they drive
their car but um but i mean
again investing will be the same thing
you're going to learn about the good
news is it's not rocket science you
don't have to be a brain surgeon to do
it
you just have to go sit down with
somebody and begin to learn a little bit
oh by the way get the financial peace
university materials back out um or i'll
plug you back in and you can go to
ramsey uh ramsey plus and get back in it
and and go through the investing lesson
again and re you know kind of go back
over because when you went through the
first time you were just worried about
debt you really weren't concentrating on
the investing stuff that we teach and
now you'll probably hear it at a
different level you think
yeah yeah i think it was definitely
something that i didn't think about the
investing piece the thing that made me
apprehensive was my dad it's really good
with finances and he had he we had a
question the other day
he really encouraged me like maybe you
do want to pay off your house first yeah
and that made me like questions so i
said i'm thinking about calling listen
if you want to follow your dad's plan
it's okay but you called me
nope that's that's what we decided to do
so thank you so much so i'm gonna i'm
gonna give you my plan not your dad's
plan
again
and so uh hold on and kelly will pick up
and we'll make sure we get you plugged
in and so i want you to go watch the uh
mutual fund and investing lesson again
in financial peace university kelly i'll
get you set up to do that on on ramsay
plus and then i want you to sit down
with smartvestor pro and once you take
your time
there's no rush
but let's get to going 15 of your income
into retirement and good growth stock
mutual funds like we teach
and then you know it doesn't sound like
you're married or got kids so you don't
need to worry about baby step five for
kids college and then anything else
above 15 you can find in your budget
we'll go and get your house paid off too
because that's we do want to do that we
just don't want to avoid something
because it scares us
uh because there's two things that scare
us things that should scare us and
things we just don't understand yet yeah
right yeah absolutely false evidence
appearing real yeah i i i resonate with
that call less for the the information
i've got a great smartvestor pro more
because
i've convinced myself that i can't
breathe underneath owing anybody
anything at any time and so there's that
balance of
could i can i race and do and pay the
house off versus
do it the right way and slow down and be
investing along the way too
and
it's less an information and more of a
psychological issue for me well and
here's the thing it's easy to understand
if you know nothing about investing yeah
it's scary as crud yeah the first time
you actually open a mutual fund account
and put money in there because it's in
this far away land known as new york
right right on wall street whatever that
is everyone on the news is yelling about
it yeah and they're all throwing stuff
down there it's crazy and
at each other and yelling and all this
and uh what is this thing and how's all
that work and
paying off debt
i understand it i give them money and
there's less debt yeah this is a fairly
simple transaction about as primitive as
it gets so it's again she
jenna you're you're
concerned your feeling is not invalid
it's not invalid at all but the point is
the people that win push past that
and get their head around new
information which gives them a new
reality for their future
and it changes the direction of your
life that's what you know
be not conformed to this world but be
transformed
by the renewing of your mind get new
information yeah yeah you know i i don't
want to be the i don't want to be
married
that way i want to be married that way
and so i need to learn what those people
over there that seem to have their act
together are doing
um i mean i see these people their
children are completely out of control
the inmates are running the asylum and
then i see these people whose children
are like
they're functional and stuff
and they're not you know they're not you
know
running up the side of the wall and
stuff and running through
throwing stuff at the glass or whatever
you know all this kind of thing and they
go okay i want those i don't want those
how did you do that that's new
information yeah and you gather that
information and you change your life
that's what transformation does
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just thirty dollars a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to feartalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality my
co-host today if you really love the
work you do
is it fulfilling for you
you know i come to work right now
because i get fired up about what we do
here
um i don't
i mean i make money but i don't work for
money and i haven't for a long long time
ken coleman america's career coach has
taken his years of proven experience to
launch one seriously power packed bundle
that combines the pre-order of his new
book from paycheck to purpose
and the new get clear assessment this is
your clear path to finding and doing
work you love
my team has packaged our new book and
career assessment into the ultimate
career bundle
all of this book assessment everything
if you buy the bundles only 30 bucks
now if you buy the assessment it's 30
bucks
so it doesn't make sense don't do that
don't do that the bundle will show you
how to find your talents your passions
your mission find a job that combines
all three so that you can actually do
the work you love
this assessment will give even give you
a list of professional career options
based on your results and it's not like
the old days this is a highly dialed in
stuff
plus you can pick between the get hired
bonus pack and they get promoted bonus
pack and receive
for free a hundred dollars worth of
other goodies so you want to check all
this out you don't have to buy the lie
that work is unfulfilling get the
ultimate career bundle go to the online
store at ramseysolutions.com
and get the new bundle for only 30 bucks
uh when you do again you're gonna get
over a hundred dollars worth of goodies
jennifer is in houston hi jennifer
welcome to the ramsey show
hi uh thank you so much for having me my
pleasure quick question uh we are on
baby step uh four six and seven um we
completed baby step three then my
husband and i have a difference of what
that looks like so would we save three
to six months worth closer to three or
six
and does that if we like say if i lose
my job today right i'm not gonna go get
my nails and hair done so like down to
the bare minimum
or what actual six month spending looks
like
uh probably between these two at your
stage
uh and you can pick the three or the
sixth month that's not the issue but
then is it absolute bare bones or does
it mean no uh
uh
known there no no hair no nails all that
kind of stuff so um
uh uh what's your household income
uh about 160 yeah
and um
how old are your two cars
uh how old uh i just bought a car for
cash of 2014 lexus and he has a uh
14 expedition okay you got two good cars
yeah
you're not you're not dying on cars
so here's the thing that i discovered
and the reason i'm asking these things
when you're broke and you're just
getting started you remember those years
back in the day
everything's a freaking emergency
because you're broke right
and you're driving junk cars
and you know you haven't done all the
maintenance on the house so even more
stuff's breaking
and so it's like you're in the fact that
you're broke is inviting more strain
on the emergency fund later on when
you've got more money
and the air conditioner is getting
serviced regularly on the house and as
soon as there's one little thing on the
roof you fix it immediately it doesn't
leak and create a bigger mess
and it's and you're driving decent cars
so they're not breaking down and you
don't wait until there's a flat tire you
happen to notice when they're going
getting a little bare and you go change
them out early where when you're broke
you have to drive them until they blow
you know and so what happens is you get
more margin in all these areas of your
life so the weird thing is is the more
money you get the less need of an
emergency fund you have
because there's fewer emergencies is
that logical
yeah absolutely and we have a 2 15 year
old and a four-year-old and then the
only other factor would be that um i'm
wondering if we should pile it up a
little more i hate my job i've been
looking at ken coleman's stuff
and my performance has not been where it
should be just because i'm i'm just
making myself get up and go to work
every day um should we add a little more
to it yeah that's not an emergency
okay that's a transition
if you want to set some money to the
side for job transition you can do that
feel free okay feel free set your 10 or
15 20 grand over there for job
transition but let's not confuse that
with the emergency fund
the emergency fund's for emergencies
this is not an emergency this is a
problem we need to fix
right christmas is not an emergency it's
always in december it's predictable
it's predictable that two years from
today you're not going to be working at
that place
god i hope not
and jennifer listen
can i can i you didn't even ask this can
i push on you for a second
please do
please
don't sacrifice your dignity and your
respectability in your work ethic
and say things like my job performance
is slipping just because i don't feel
like going anymore
if you're still employed they're still
taking their money show up and give a
thousand percent and then when you're
looking for jobs give a thousand percent
on your job transition
but you will it will keep you from
walking six inches lower right with your
head held up you will walk with your
head held high your chin held up you
will clean out your desk when you get
that new job with a smile on your face
yeah i don't know
you're not a person that mails it in no
that's not who you are
yeah so but yeah go ahead and make the
transition and set some money aside for
that and if you want to um
what's happening is is that transition
is scaring you and that's what's making
you want to put the emergency fund on up
and so put 25 000 over there right quick
in the next few months to make this
transition that's not that's a
transition fund it's not an emergency
fund and then you then you won't be
worried about your emergency fund
anymore because your emergency fund
probably just fine i love that idea dave
so that's the you would a transition a
new baby coming you need to get a new
car none of those are emergencies those
are just we need to have a sinking fund
that we create and save up for that yeah
you know what the problem is and it's
not her situation but it's just all of
us in america we were just taught to
have a savings account that's it that's
exactly right one and you know what a
savings account is it's a put and take
account you put money in there you take
it out put money in there take it out
and buy a bass boat put money in there
fix air conditioner put money in there
put stitches in the kid's head put money
in there okay so put and take put and
take put and take and so it's all this
stuff is combined in this one general
account that that you always watch it
and it just never seems to do what it's
supposed to do because no one knows what
it's really supposed to do it's never
enough or look at all that money i got
right yeah and when you separate out
your savings and you say every savings
dollar has to have a job
a mission an assignment okay this is you
this one's job is transition
this one's job is christmas this one's
job is car replacement and this one's
jobs emergencies and don't confuse them
i love that buying a bass boat is not an
emergency there is no situation ever on
planet earth in which you can describe a
bass boat purchase as an emergency it's
not on the list i can emotionally get
there but intellectually we're all
laughing right now right and so you know
that that's i was forced to buy a new
car no you aren't they didn't have a gun
you chose to buy a new car and so these
are the things but that's the reason is
it and it helped me a ton
uh because my nature's not a i'm not
naturally a saver it helped me a ton to
say these things have a goal because i
am goal oriented and once i have
something with a goal then ding ding
ding ding i can do it i love i'm writing
that down every
savings dollar has a job too
different than your light bill or your
food or what
every every dollar you are saving has a
job as well it's a little bit of the
frustration of when you're investing
just in general
and what do we do we call it we're
saving for retirement yeah what does
that even mean what does retirement even
mean and uh
you know
we started saying a few years ago around
here you know retirement's not a number
it's not a number it's a it's a it's not
a it's not a destination it's not a
thing so all we're really saying is we
want to build some wealth
but when you don't even have that you
know it's just very vague it's like i
just want a big pile of money yeah
there's it's not motivating nope but if
you say you know i want to build a
hospital for children
and that's going to cost
40 million dollars i need 40 million
dollars now you got something you're
aiming at i can go get it yeah then you
can go get it you got a reason for doing
this it changes everything
very cool stuff
dr john dolone ramsey personality my
co-host today this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
jared and katie are with us hey guys how
are you hi hello welcome welcome good to
have you guys so here to do a debt free
scream how much did you pay off
we paid off 110 000 and wow
nine months good for you nine months and
your range of income during that time
200 to 250. what do you guys do for a
living
i'm a digital marketing analyst
and i am in marketing and sales for a
large media company awesome very cool
good for you guys great careers
obviously great income what kind of debt
was the 110 000
mostly credit card debt so
a small portion was car payment um but
it wasn't very much it's about six
thousand for the car a lot of credit
card debt how long have you guys been
married
19 years
19 years 19 years married when you were
four
wow yeah i was about to say three or
four years you all look so young
19 years yes okay so is this like 19
years of slightly overspending every
year and you looked up and it was 90 or
100 grand or was it like you had two or
three little events and you just went
nuts i'd say we never really had a
budget we didn't really know how to do
it and didn't really think about it
and then we had a house and
it flooded and we had moved to tennessee
and we were going to rent it out it was
in virginia and
we just um that was a big portion of it
paying off paying two mortgages
okay um that escalated it to the hundred
thousand range
so half of it was just steady stupidity
and then half of it was big problems
right exactly yeah which is always how
it goes right so a year
or so ago
right covered time
something
the phone rang and there was a wake-up
call you had an oh crap moment or
something what happened tell me about it
yeah we were um finally able to sell the
other house so it was hit by a storm and
it took them four years to rebuild it
and we finally sold it
and got off the market and but we didn't
make any money off of it yeah we didn't
make any money off of it and we looked
at where we were and we're like well
this is horrible
we can't continue to do this yeah we
make too much money to be this broke
yeah and we're just juggling our debt
well i was just juggling our debt and
then i was keeping some of it from her
so she wouldn't realize
how how bad we were
oh how is that conversation that's hard
i didn't know as much as i should have
and i just was assuming it was going to
get better and
you know we'll figure out college for
the kids and
you know when we had that conversation
it you know took a little bit of
counseling a little bit of talking and
we talked about the book and um we
decided to gung-ho go all in yeah i um i
knew we had to do something i reached
out to my friend carolyn who works here
and um just said hey
um i i really have some debt that i need
to take care of um i know you work with
dave what do you what are you guys is
all that stuff real or not yeah you know
does that work and the next day i i mean
literally the next day i had your book
in my mailbox she was like almost like
she hand delivered it to me um and i
read it and then katie read it and we
said
if we're going to do this we're going to
do this and it's been the best thing
so the total money makeover baby steps
just go all in all in all
it's all or nothing we got the kids on
board they were super psyched
how old are your kids we have twins that
are 14 and one is 12.
so jared most of the time
when i hear
uh she didn't know about all of the debt
um
there's a percentage of the time it's uh
you're just being deceitful and you're
doing all the scrap on the side i didn't
want to know about but most of the time
that's not what it is most of the time
it's like this is my job and i feel
ashamed that i have failed
and let this get this bad and i don't
want to admit it out loud yeah is that
kind of what it was it was holding back
because it wasn't like you were setting
out to deceiver no it's my
responsibility to take care of her you
know i felt that obviously that's not
true but
that's that's that's the types that play
yeah yeah it's my responsibility i'm
head of household i'm gonna fix this
eventually let me just keep keep it in
the air until i can deal with it yeah so
yeah it was rough that that was hard on
our marriage too so yeah what was the
moment you said we need to talk
um it was after that we when the house
sold yeah when the house sold that was
kind of the kicker it was like okay
what does this do for us this is um this
we're still in the same spot
we want to buy a house we've been
renting here for six years and we love
franklin tennessee it's amazing um
wanted to buy a house and um it was now
like well how are we gonna do that i
still have
and i didn't even know we had a hundred
thousand dollars
you know it
it was so unattainable to be debt-free
that i just didn't even care at that
point i was i why even look at it i'm
just juggling yeah
so katie not to put you guys on the spot
but this is a great story of redemption
really um uh and it's good for other
people to hear yeah because there's
what you guys have gone through is like
almost everybody goes through this exact
same thing so he comes in and says
uh
i gotta talk this is he's kind of like
laying down his pride
and saying
this is screwed up it's on me
but it's worse than you ever dreamed
what did you hear when he said that
yeah it was very hard to hear that that
was the reality um and i actually did
feel like i had some responsibility too
it's my job to also know it is what i'm
saying i mean but was it like fear that
you heard yes
mad at him for for not telling the truth
or what yes she's too nice to admit she
was she was angry there was a lot of
anger and
i it took me a while to understand why
you know it's like well this is you know
it's my job and part of it's part of
it's angry because you're in the whole
situation right and part of it is
because he didn't tell you yeah of
course that we're never going to get
through it we're never going to get out
of it why did i not know why didn't you
tell me um yeah and we've
somewhat dealt with this earlier in our
marriage and it was just a big pile of
it and we you know we wanted to finally
like get to a good place well the reason
i bring it up is you're a great example
of a healthy
way of handling this because most people
don't handle it healthy that's right it
explodes right and then there's shrapnel
everywhere and especially on those three
beautiful little kids right yeah yeah
and we couldn't let that happen
and that was the beautiful thing about
this is the kids got to see us actually
do this and we get to explain to them
this is why we're not doing everything
we used to do and this is why i'm saying
no to this and we're going to do it
right and we're doing it together which
and they they smell the air change in
your marriage yes
the cleanliness and the connectivity
they you can't keep that that stuff's in
the air that's right yeah and
this is a whole other show but you
alluded to it a little bit a
conversation like hey we're a hundred
thousand dollars in credit card debt and
i haven't told you there's other stuff
you all needed to talk about too
and the whole the oxygen filtering your
home is lighter now right everybody in
your home is different now because you
all had the courage to put on the table
to forgive one another to say i'm sorry
to say let's build something new were
you there
that's exactly what it was it's made our
marriages 100 better so well
congratulations you changed an entire
legacy of those three little boys you've
changed your legacy and there's millions
of people are stuck thanks for letting
us drag all that out because because not
not it's not for you it's for all the 22
million people listening because
everybody if you can go hey everybody
messes up but here's there's there's
hope the other side of the mess up you
know so congratulations for you guys
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
gazelle focused okay
uh communication is the key to
everything right like communication is
the key to marriage but for sure in this
story it's just focus and keep going
just keep going you made plenty of money
so as soon as you just decided and both
of you were game on and everything's on
the table you just went after it oh yeah
most of that was going to credit card
interest just boom just got surprised
have a plastic surgery party and go to
town yeah yeah it was just focus well
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you and the total money makeover
another one so you can give that one
away to somebody because you probably
know somebody like your friend carol
that works here knew somebody so there
you go congratulations i'm very proud of
you you're a very cool couple i love it
very neat 110 000 paid off in nine
months making 200 to 250 it's jared and
katie from nashville count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're
[Applause]
love
done
so yes
yes
your show and this show will always be
intertwined
always
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john baloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at eight eight
two five
five two two five briana is with us in
cincinnati hi brianna how are you
hi i'm blessed how are y'all better than
i deserve what's up
um i just had a question so i'm 23 um i
have two kids under five
and i want to go back to school i've
been taking some online classes
um
towards like a associate's degree but
i'm ready to actually like put it in
full gear
and get a degree in economics
so i can
better our life it's just scary
to leave my job that i have now
and pursue that
so i just wanted to we're single
yeah well i'm married but we're
separated so that's a whole another
that's a whole another
uh talk i guess
okay and um what is the goal
career-wise with an economics degree
well
i think
it's just like i want to go to law
school so
i was looking at degrees that you know
could give me
other opportunities if i ended up not
wanting to go to law school
but i've always wanted to so
um
so honey i worked at a lot
i worked at a law school
they'll take you
man we had students with literature
degrees and psychology degrees and math
degrees and analysts
economics by itself doesn't sound like a
degree that's going to be easy to roll
out of law school with
data analyst yeah absolutely yes
business yes
um
economics
i don't know a lot about that but i
don't think that's as viable as an
option as you think it might be okay so
here what john john is a phd in higher
education he's worked in universities
his whole life okay
uh until until just a couple years ago
when he came here
and so um
uh what we're looking for is uh if you
don't go to law school which degree
that could have gotten you into law
school also gets you into a great job if
you choose not to go to law school
that's what he's talking about so right
now any job will get you i mean any
degree will get you into law school so
let's put that on the back burner and go
with what dave's about to talk about
let's get a degree that's that gets you
into a position right to make money
because that's what you're looking at is
how to better your life now how in the
world are you paying for all of this
including feeding these two kids while
you do all of this
yeah so i make ten dollars and 22 cents
an hour right now um
and i'm barely at work because i'm the
only caretaker
so i'm barely even making any money but
i'm on food stamps of course
i live in public housing so i'm blessed
to that aspect but i really just want to
get out of it you know what i'm saying
get out of poverty my whole family's got
the history i just want to
get out so
i
yes
agreed
and how are you paying for it
college financial aid is covering it
okay so you're going to go
pell grant straight up
yeah but student loans are tempting you
know because of my situation so
they'll guarantee that you stay in
poverty is what they'll do exactly yeah
they don't go away
they don't leave
they stick around forever
until you pay them they're a problem
so pell grants will cover your tuition
correct
yeah they'll cover a bachelor um
so the law school is another story but
yeah
law school you can probably get
scholarship to as a single mother
living on public assistance you're
probably going to find a law school that
wants you and wants to pay for it for
you
that would be a that would be a doable
thing absolutely the goal here what i
don't want you to do is put the cart
before the horse your job is to
you've got a journey ahead of you and
what you really want to do now you've
made this decision to get out of poverty
you want to do it tomorrow
and that's not going to be your journey
your journey is going to be going to
school
fighting every temptation to take out a
loan that you have to turn on and pay
back
and you're going to get through it debt
free and you're going to work and you're
going to be exhausted
and you're going to have to call on
friends and family and you're going to
have to meet people and you're going to
have to ask for help and you're going to
grind and grind and grind and then you
can end up with a bachelor's degree that
is free and clear that nobody can ever
take away from you that you don't know
what i'm on none
it's yours now we're in a position
to if you do this in a way that is um
you know the way we're talking about it
and if you select a degree that lands
you in a type of career
that um
that not only prospers you but that you
enjoy
yeah that's my main concern too so what
i want you to do is just jump on
kingcoleman.com and go through a bunch
of his materials i'll tell you what i'm
going to give you the get clear
assessment
and uh and the ken coleman's new book
coming out uh from paycheck to purpose
i'm going to give you that whole bundle
free kelly will pick up and get that all
set up for you now the book won't come
until later because it doesn't come out
until november but we'll send you the
assessment now i want you to take the
assessment tonight
okay and i want you to use that to help
guide you into what you want to study so
that you're studying something that fits
your talents your passions your mission
and um and you're looking at it and
going okay if i was one of those i could
make 80 000 a year and now i'm done with
this poverty crap
yeah and that's if i don't go to law
school
so let's plan this out that you're not
going to law school
okay and then if you go to law school
it's gravy on the biscuit that's right
yeah that's true and brianna you are
changing a family system so you know
what you're going to need in your life
you're going to need strong brilliant
women who you can have coffee with who
will be honest with you but who have
managed businesses before who have
graduated college you've walked the road
you're about to walk because you're
heading off into the woods by yourself
because your family the models the
pictures you have don't include this and
their pictures of you don't include it
and so they're not gonna they don't mean
to be mean but there's something about a
family system that'll drag you back down
to their level every time unless you've
got a real breakthrough
group around you
okay so when you go to class i want you
to get involved and i know it's hard you
got two little kids and every minute
feel weird like you're like you're the
old woman
you will provide 23 wisdom and value for
them and vice versa and this will become
your community i'm so
so proud of you yeah this is amazing
you're incredible you're amazing your
kids are going to be blessed to have
walked this journey with you okay
but find some people find some people
that walk look and talk and are like you
want to be in five years and hang out
with them they will lift you up to there
people who are not there will it hold
you down to where they are
okay you become who you hang around with
and
those kids dad needs to put some money
on the table too
yeah well that's that's part of this
little separation here
yeah but good luck with that yeah um
should should that's the whoo yeah
that's a whole other call like it's my
blood pressure boiling yeah i noticed
that and i saw that little thing
happening on your forehead there the
little bump pump yeah so uh yeah that's
but but here's the thing you're a hero
hang on kelly i'll pick up we'll get you
in the uh get clear assessment take that
tonight i'm gonna furnish it to you free
along with all of ken's goodies and uh
bundle on his new book and everything
because that's what you're exactly where
you need to be
uh
because sometimes
uh folks you you
if no one in your family or your friend
group has ever taken this journey
then you can take the journey wrong
because you don't have a good guide
right
and um
the biggest mistakes
in the student loan debacles that are
out there in terms of how much debt they
go into
and studying stupid unusable degrees
come from first generation college
students
no one in their family ever went to
college before and everybody in the
family wants them to go to college but
nobody knows how to do it wisely that's
exactly right and that that's how you
end up 260 thousand dollars in debt with
a degree in left-handed puppetry right
because all education is good horse crap
right no it's not all education is
valuable no it's not
not all education has a market value
that is worth what you pay for it
definitely not right some more valuable
than others uh but you know so you got
to get a bit utilitarian about this and
go what is the actual application in the
marketplace
that first decision is big and she's
there hey man she's got to do it right
amen bust through girl good for her you
call us anytime you need some help we're
here we're not going anywhere
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money it's a free call here
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five the dr john daloni
show is all about boundaries anxiety
mental health
uh
in this crazy world we live in you need
somebody saying to talk to and he's your
guy
he's on monday wednesday and friday on a
new podcast every one of those three
days anywhere great podcasts are found
and it's streamed on youtube as well so
be sure and check it out and the dr john
deloney show uh the fastest growing
program in the ramsey lineup these days
absolutely exploding so he's here right
now also to answer your questions the
phone number again triple eight eight
two five five two two five sebastian's
in little rock hi sebastian how are you
hey guys i'm doing great uh i'm getting
some career advice over here okay so i'm
21 years old i just got married like two
months ago congratulations
thank you we just paid off my wife's
student loans about twenty thousand wow
dollars
and now i'm thinking about going to
graduate school and i just want to know
if that's the you know
night right
makes right move for me what do you want
to go to grad school here
so i want to go to like you know the big
schools i want to go to mit or stanford
and get my phd in data science
just because i love all that stuff and
i've been involved with research a lot
during my undergrad years and as far as
i know
uh grad school for especially that
program it's all paid for like you have
to type into your rip off
and then they pay for your books and
insurance intuition and all that right
yep uh
but financially speaking if i did get my
phd and i got the same job
uh you know like right out of college
i'll probably just be making like what
10 to 15 more
by having that phd degree
so i'm kind of debating if it's really
worth you know spending four or five
years into
uh working on your thesis working in a
research project
just to get that little bit more extra
cash at the end
so there was it's been a couple years
since i read the study so i'm going to
butcher it up a little bit but
distilled all the way down if you can
get into a phd program in data science
at one of those two schools
the connections you make inside that
program meaning the folks who are
creating businesses that would co-create
businesses with you that would co-create
new knowledge that y'all would go on to
build new products etc
um
would it could have a potential an
infinite return
and so if you're able to if you were my
friend and you said hey i have an
opportunity to go get a free phd in data
science at mit or at stanford i would
say i will come visit you in boston or
southern california
or central california
the other side of it is ask yourself is
that the life you want
because you are right the next four five
or six or seven years of your life
will be chasing down a problem
a central problem we'll be writing
papers doing math equations going to
things and not making a whole bunch of
money and if you have the competition of
power inside your own head to get into
those programs you have the opportunity
to go earn money right now a whole lot
of it
right
right what's your undergrad and again
uh so my undergrad will be in computer
science engineering and physics and
applied mathematics
okay yeah so you gotta ask what do you
wanna what life do you wanna live
so ideally in my mind i would like to
start my own business have like a
startup idea that relates to your ai or
machine learning and then be able to you
know be able to run that business and
also spend time with my family and my
wife so do you have
do you have the benefit of going to
those programs is
it's iron sharpens irons you're running
around the smartest mines
exactly on the planet in some of those
areas and do you have the ability from
wherever you are in little rock to start
an ai company that's gonna does that
make sense do you have the tools that
you need at your disposal or is being
around that type of sparring partner
gonna be worth your time
hypothetically yes i do have the tools
and like the ability to do that right
now practically though it would be more
challenging it's not the same you know
being in the valley in silicon valley
sure developing ideas and all of them
being in literally
sure but
so don't worry
um
i i think the mit phd issue uh it sounds
really fun and really challenging and in
a lot of ways um i think the play there
is for one half of a one percent
probability
it's a very narrow play
um that you can actually get in and get
that one no no no you can get in and get
through it i think this guy can do that
uh but then what do you actually end up
doing with that that makes that
beneficial right it's a very small play
and if you think and if you and if you
hit it it's a home run that's right but
it's not uh it's not as broad a play the
broader play
that has a higher probability is to say
i'm going to go right now and get a job
as a data analyst with some of the top
data analyst people in the world
at a tech based company that's really
forward thinking and is doing a bunch of
ai stuff and i'm going to get in there
and rub shoulders with those guys in the
business world and i'm going to spend
i'm going to make you know 100 the first
year 200 300 the third year and um
and then i'm going to be from that in a
position
with my business acumen and having
rubbed shoulders with some guys put a
little bit of a little bit longer in the
tooth i'll be in a position to start a
business
that you obviously to start and run a
data analyst business you do not need a
phd absolutely not the only benefit of
the other thing is the iron sharpens
iron and hanging around with smart
people and you become smarter as a
result of doing that so i i i i
if you want to be a professor someday
which you told me you don't want to
right yeah you want to start your own
business run his own business and run
your own business
uh the the
the lift is probably not worth the the
trip no and if you want a life that i
want to hang out with my family i want
to make some money i want to
go yeah go get a great job man yeah and
i i i think you go get in and here's the
other thing the particular field that
you're in
i mean we've got uh
450 tech folk on our team
uh data analysts we've got uh data
scientists we've got uh platform
engineers and people that do stuff i'm
not even sure what they do and they're
on our payroll but uh and they're
unbelievably smart oh they're incredible
unbelievably smart we got a real tech
company here
hidden behind a radio show
and um uh but the uh uh
what i have figured out having written
all these checks for these people for
years now
is that that the rate of change in your
world sebastian is blinding yes
while you are doing this phd the world
is going to completely change four times
and uh you know and i think you'll have
a better chance of staying
up with that change in industry than you
will in academia
that's my opinion yeah what do you think
i don't i don't know enough about i
would hope that the if you're studying
ai it's moving ahead of where the
industry is that's my hope but who knows
man maybe you're leading the industry
that could be
but the you know you got to keep up with
the rate of change either place that's
right because four years from today
you're going to be obsolete in that
world if you haven't kept up with the
rate of change if you're not ready for a
phd program if you're not 100 in go get
a job make great money be with your
family and start from there
[Music]
this
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org
don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
does it feel like no matter how hard you
work you can't seem to get ahead
you're stuck
i know how that feels it's exhausting
sometimes it's even terrifying
you don't have to live like that if
you're sick and tired of being sick and
tired decide
that you're ready to do something about
it you're ready to do something
different so you get different results
it's time to commit to a plan that
actually works financial peace
university is the step-by-step plan
that's helping over 6 million people pay
off debt and take control of their money
combine that with a premium version of
the every dollar budgeting tool and you
will make progress right away and it's
only available with a membership to
ramsey plus
decide today
to break the cycle of living paycheck to
paycheck this month only we're taking 30
off the price of a 12-month membership
start with a free trial of ramsey plus
today text trial
to 33 789 the free trial text trial
two three three
seven eight nine hugo is in maryland hi
hugo welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey john how are you guys great
man what's up
hey so i have a question about your
recommended growth and aggressive growth
mutual funds which i know they translate
loosely into mid-caps and small cap
funds
within those funds
there are blend funds which have growth
and value stocks
what do you think of blend funds
as opposed to just strictly using a
growth investment strategy in those
specific market caps
either one's fine
uh what you're looking for is a track
record
a long track record
giving you a positive rate of return
it's that simple and so i mean if you
can compare if you want to compare some
that's got some blends and some value in
it and it outperforms a straight on
growth strategy
across the board and you're comfortable
with that that's fine it still qualifies
the bottom line is we're participating
in the stock market in a way that beats
the indexes
that's what you're looking for
and so you know if you're in the growth
area then you'd want to outperform the s
p
if you're in the aggressive growth you'd
want to outperform the russell
and that's your index that's your your
benchmark your watermark
otherwise you could just invest in the
index funds which is the the bogle
strategy john bogle famous for that he
started the no load uh
s p 500 at vanguard the very first one
and started the whole passive investment
movement because a high percentage of
mutual funds over half of them don't
outperform the indexes so what you're
looking for regardless of what the
internal mix is is something that
generally fits those categories and will
beat those indexes that's how i pick my
personal funds
but it's not it's really not rocket
science um and here's the other thing
it's very good that you're asking this
question
it's a very intelligent question it's a
question that indicates you're a fairly
sophisticated investor this is not your
first ride on the cabbage truck
let me warn you though about something
that we found in the millionaire study
that we did
the vast majority of those millionaires
were mediocre in their sophistication of
investing
sometimes guys like you and me
that are a little more nerdy and we
enjoy the nuance of all of this that
because i'm having fun talking to you
about it can you tell
you know and so we enjoy the nuance of
it we can get paralysis of the analysis
and do nothing while the other guy does
a lot of things but just does the medium
and he kicks our butt in total net
worth when the story's over in other
words in actually doing the investing
mediocre versus not doing it and having
a bunch of theories makes people rich
and so that's that's the thing you don't
want to get caught up in and go i get
paralyzed by these nuanced comparisons
and uh you know so i mean like people
come at me all the time and they're like
oh you know
you should just do the bogle thing and
just do all indexes hey if you just do
all indexes
and you put 15 of your income into
retirement you're going to be a
multi-millionaire
i got no problem with that go do it do
something yeah go do it but that's
better than than sitting around having a
big long lengthy discussion you're
writing a money blog in your mother's
basement or going from bitcoin to the
next thing to the yeah beanie based yeah
going to be the chapter of my next title
in my next chapter beanie babies to
bitcoin i like it it's a get-rich-quick
chapter that's right you know and so
you're chasing your tail and you're not
because i actually did have dubers back
in the day say they were investing their
money in beanie babies absolutely i
remember them they were just and they're
like i put my kids college and beanie
babies i thought they were joking but
you know there's just and you know if
it's not that it's the iraqi dinar or
there's always some stupid now hugo is
not doing that right he's just asking
for
the nuances within the nuances and
within the things that we suggest so
he's still fine he's you're he's in
bounds he's in bounds he's going to get
a touchdown but you something about that
question
sets off in you
when you start going real deep real deep
real deep
you're dangerously close to doing
nothing or to just need to read another
paper and one more paper here's the
thing the interesting thing is the data
tells us that what makes people wealthy
is actually investing more so than the
rate of return
that's the thing you know and but it and
and that is lost on
people who love looking for a tenth of a
point yes on something they're shaving
something and again i'm not picking on
hugo but oh it's great but uh you know
it's one of the biggest knocks on dave
ramsey ramsay doesn't know what he's
doing yeah i actually do know what i'm
doing because i actually get people to
freaking invest right which is more
important than all this other bs people
talk about and again not picking on hugo
because i love having these discussions
i love nerding out on this stuff but uh
uh and i love digging around in the
mutual fund scratching around in there
trying to find one beats the index just
to prove i can out boggle bogle right
but uh but bogal's brilliant yeah i mean
he you know he he kind of democratized
invest investing in a sense because it's
anybody can do it just take the dead gum
index fund and go to sleep
and you know it's uh it's freaking car
automatically drive itself you know but
if you'll keep doing that you'll be a
multi-millionaire yeah that's awesome
but the the you know the there's a lot
of other factors that come in
if i can just get you to invest and
never stop investing anytime there's a
coveted blip uh uh you know
a a war uh uh a scare of this or a scare
of that toilet paper or whatever
whatever whatever it is whatever reason
it is that you're next scared about the
stock market if i can just get you to
ignore that and just keep going and keep
going and keep going keep going and keep
going keep going
man
99 of the time i'm gonna make you rich
doing that even if we screw up and oh he
has those aren't no load mutual funds
they charge commissions who gives crap
you know you're actually doing it and
the guy that's getting the commission's
causing you to keep doing it and there
if you keep doing it you're gonna have
money so i love hugo i love these ideas
and these questions but it's just
it's a little bit frustrating because a
math guy like me we wish it was a little
bit tricky
more complex so we could we could figure
out the little trick yeah and we could
go do it you know
and all the regular people that aren't
math nerds couldn't do it yes but the
problem is anybody can do it exactly
right if you just do it and do it and do
it and do it and do it and do it or do
it or do it good question though hugo
thank you man fun discussion keith's in
phoenix hey keith what's up
gentlemen thanks for taking my call and
i'm not sure my question is going to be
as exciting as the last one but uh
not anything much more exciting than
comparing value funds i'm just saying
i'll give it a shot anyway but uh so
here's the deal we're uh my wife and i
are halfway uh to a fully funded
emergency excuse me emergency fund we're
looking at about march of next year to
be done good with that but we we have
two cars in one of them because of the
values being a little bit higher now
we're contemplating whether we should
sell one of those which we could
probably get about forty five thousand
dollars for
we need about twenty thousand dollars
more to fund that emergency fund
but i'm a little bit hesitant to do that
so when you're coming for household
income
uh we're about a hundred and
forty hundred fifty
[Music]
what's the other car worth
the other car the second car is worth
about five thousand dollars i'd keep it
but they're
they're both paid for i keep the forty
five thousand dollars
it's not online
it's not a problem
because here's what's going to happen if
you sell that car this time next year
you're going to be shopping for a dead
gum car
and you know that's just you should have
just kept that one
now i'd hold on to it
it's not that big a deal you're in good
shape you got a nice car it's within
your range you're fine keep it this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
todd is in fort wayne indiana it says on
my screen todd you're debt-free
congratulations
thank you very much dave how much you
pay off brother
245 000
and 10 and a half years wow no longer
journey love it and your range of income
during that ten and a half years
started at 45 000 i am now a hundred and
ten thousand now excellent what do you
do for a living
pharmaceutical sales now cool very cool
so i'm guessing with this length of time
this huge amount of money maybe you paid
off your house
uh not the house but quite a bit uh we
started our journey my wife and i at the
time uh
when we were pregnant with our twins
which would have been number three and
four
and uh we started even knowing that she
had to stay home and she chose to do
that and um so
we had to get our money under control
real quick i had already been listening
to you and so being the nerd that i am i
have a excel spreadsheet
you know from 2008 when i started
listening to you to the time we started
in 2010
and uh it's just been an awesome awesome
opportunity wow you all see this wow so
you you hustle i mean you just grind and
grind and grind ten and a half years
later wow was it mostly student loans
yeah student loans was the enormous part
of it yes yes getting my masters and
paying off my wife's debt as well for
student loans so it was quite a bit in
there
your master's in
a business okay she get an mba
i do have the mba yes okay cool very
cool what's her degree in
uh teaching okay teaching so we've
done a good job and unfortunately last
year we separated but uh i know she's
debt-free
leaving that marriage and
so
we're both debt-free to my knowledge and
i'm excited you know that she's able to
move on and go in that direction and
then for myself but just look forward to
spending time with more of my
my four kids and i sent some pictures in
we were able after getting that free to
go on vacation and hit up several
national parks over the summer before
all the fire season started so it was
awesome
looks like an epic trip yeah tough time
in their lives too huh
right right
so
but i've been able to teach the class
actually twice at church uh three times
at the community center and helped a lot
of people along the way and a lot of
people were way ahead of me but i knew
i'd see the end of the light
and now i'm here so what kept you going
for a decade brother that's a long time
to be committed to something
yes
long time coming what kept you what kept
you going
i i'm big into numbers and that's why
like i said i have an excel excel
spreadsheet going back all the way to
2008 before we started the program and
after i started listening to you and
it's just you know i just keep going and
it gives me motivation to see it i do it
every month
look at the number bottom line number
every month and know that i'm making
progress and that's how i
measure my progress
wow
well congratulations i'm very very proud
of you yeah what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is you've
taught the class you paid off 245 000
you're an expert what's the secret
stay focused it's hard sometimes
there's a lot of temptation to get out
of it and not follow it but
you stick with it you will
you will make it set your goals and be
focused while i've got you
backing out a hundred thousand dollars
would you recommend to your former self
that mba is worth it we should pay a
full price for that executive mba
program has it helped you or would you
go back and do it again differently
um
it helped me with my with my business
and you know all the jobs i've had but
in terms of how much money it'd be
questionable at this point
that's a that's a very common answer
well brother i'm proud of you man so
what do you tell um what are you passing
along to your kids here in this in this
new season
well they know that
there's a limited amount of money that
they're going to receive and they know
the bottom line when dad says no it's no
and but they also know how to make money
they
my oldest is trying to start her own
business
and uh she's not even out in out of high
school yet and my twins sell
produce out of the front of our farm and
uh so every fall so it's really kind of
cool so they've gotten the bug
very cool and they know that dad's
committed to it to help them
very neat
well congratulations brother thank you
for teaching the class and uh you did it
man ten and a half years wow pretty
amazing we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story and a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away to
somebody i'm sure you know how to do
that after teaching the class and get
somebody else started on this journey
and uh man you gotta you got a wide open
thing in front of you now to the next
chapter turn the page turn the page turn
the page
all right todd in fort wayne indiana i'm
sorry
thank you so much for all your help i
appreciate it thank you sir todd in fort
wayne indiana 245 000 paid off in 10 and
a half years making 45 to 110. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
angie is with us in phoenix hey angie
what's up
hi i am getting ready to retire my
husband
and i well i'm 58 my husband will be 59
and i'm getting ready to sign the
retirement papers and
want to know if that's going to be a
good thing for us
sounds like you're doing it
we want to do it yes
okay um
but
we have a pension that we're going to
get and it's it's on the rule of 80. we
paid 5 into it so it makes sense to take
the pension we'll be getting 120 000 a
year
um we have about 400 equity in our house
although we owe 200
200 000 dollars on it you have a nest
egg
yes we have um
for between the 457 and 401a between the
both of us is 750 000 and we have our
three month emergency fund of 25 000. so
you're millionaires congratulations
we thank you
and your question your question is is it
okay to retire
is it okay to retire what we're thinking
about doing
is um because we haven't we don't have
the house paid off and our money as you
know is in the 401k 457. we're gonna
have to pay taxes on that stuff but i
want to make sure we have enough money
for funds so we're going to be um can
you live what do you what do you make
now what's your household income before
you retire
um we we each make about a hundred
thousand so two hundred
thousand so it's gonna drop to one it's
gonna drop to 120 can you make it
bad
hold on tight are you holding on to
something with both hands are you going
to be all right
yeah i think so and so if you use some
of this money in your nest egg that
you're not going to use anyway to live
on because you're living on the pension
and you use some of it to pay pay a
little taxes and pay off your house
that'd be a good thing
that'd be an excellent thing which would
also give you more wiggle room in the
120 by the way because you don't have a
house payment anymore
great that's what we're hoping for do it
do it pay off the house thank you i've
listened to you forever
i appreciate it we just got out of debt
um this last cove um the march 2019
around that time period period
so we're really excited well you've done
a great job handling your money over a
long period of time it sounds like and
uh here you are at 58 years old you're
millionaires everyday millionaires way
to go this is how you do it now uh
the warning is you're awfully young to
do nothing go deuce you find a mission
or a purpose or something yes
okay definitely don't just do nothing
sitting on the couch watching oprah
reruns bad plan because nothing is not
good for the soul and paying for his
funeral is going to be expensive right
because you're going to kill him
you're going to bury him in the yard
you've got to have something to go
towards and then you'll be a ward of the
state that's exactly right oh no no no
no no no yeah let's let's not go so dark
so quick john my gosh this is what
happens that's just what happens i kill
him and bury him in the yard
why don't we just get some something to
do with our hands here let's let's
something to lay our hands no shovels
yes you're right
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day john 14 6 jesus
answered i am the way
the truth
and the life
no one comes to the father
except through me
charles swindoll said life is ten
percent what happens to you and ninety
percent how you respond to it dr john
dolone ramsey personality is my co-host
today julia is in new york hi julia how
are you
hi mr ramsay hi john i'm good a little
nervous and excited how are you guys
great how can we help
uh yes so it's just some quick
background information and then my
question um my husband and i were a
young couple we just had a baby uh nine
months ago
thank you thank you so much um we're
looking to get out of new york we're
just north out of new york city um just
craziness going on here very restrictive
we want to move down south to florida
we just want to know if it's a good idea
to
sell our house now since the market is
so hot we are pretty house poor 60 of
our income goes to the house
and if we should sell and then rent down
there
and if we do that should we throw our
money at the proceeds at the debt and or
and save some to live off of since we do
have a baby and it's a big move going
down there you know across you know down
the coast um just kind of looking for
some guidance on if this is a good move
or not for us
well if it's a good move is up to you
guys that that part i can't decide for
you it sounds like you've already made
the decision to me
but um and and so and there's nothing
wrong with the move that you're
describing or your reasons as far as i'm
concerned
um the uh
as far as what to do with the money part
um how much debt do you have
not counting you're not counting your
house
okay not counting the house we have
about 75 000 in consumer debt right and
what will the
how much equity will come free when you
sell the house how much money will you
have in your hand from the house sale um
i would say at least between 100 and 150
depending okay
so yes i would write a check that day
and be debt-free
i would move to florida and um you got
75 000 to put down on something if you
want to buy something have you got jobs
lined up
uh not yet i mean i i'm not going back
to work this year i'm a teacher of the
deaf i'm going to stay home with the
baby and my husband works for the
railroad so he's going to keep working
we're just going to you know make ends
meet on his income and
can he move his railroad
job to florida
uh well he he's he thinks it's very
promising that he'll find something down
there for sure he's been looking for and
there's a lot of openings it's just a
matter of okay that's fine
that's step one yeah we don't go to
florida and hope
right julia i hear you
on that i hear on your voice that you
are in a panic you've backed yourself
into a corner we got to do it right now
the market's hot if we don't do it
and you got to breathe because what
you're going to do is you're going to
jump off the dock and there's going to
be no boat down there and you're going
to have a little nine month old baby and
you and your husband trying to tread
water
yeah
you're good slow down okay slow down a
little bit
you're all right
there's nothing i think everything going
on with that with new york it's just
kind of i got you i i don't blame you
for wanting to uh
you know it's a bad science fiction
movie escape from new york right i mean
so
a lot of people are doing it a lot of
people escaping from california there's
a lot of that happening a lot of
migration in america right now um and
it's not due to covet it's due to
freedom
and so lots of people lots of people
making the decision you're making right
now and so that's okay but slow down two
beats john's exactly right so beat one
is husband goes and gets a job the
faster he does that you can go to beat
two
and that's put the house on the market
and sell it
then you can decide are we going to rent
or are we going to buy in florida
because we're going to write a 75 000
check and be 100 debt free see if you
move to florida and you have 75 000 in
the bank and your husband has a job and
you run a little while no big deal
if you move to florida and you have 75
000 in the bank and he does not have a
job you're going to burn through that
money and you're going to be fretting
and anxiety ridden and looking at this
nine month old going how we're gonna
feed it and you're gonna be all this
other stuff going on then he's gonna end
up taking a crappy job and then you're
gonna wish you hadn't moved
yeah yeah you're right and then whatever
politicians gonna get voted out with the
flavor of the month and new york's gonna
come back to sanity and you're gonna go
what do we do
that's what i want you to to exhale
just
exhale get this in the right he needs a
job
faster he gets a job the faster you put
the house on the market the faster you
put the house on the market the faster
you move
and as soon as you move you're debt-free
and when you do that
then we can breathe and it's okay to
rent for six months and take the 75 000
and look and learn the area get
comfortable get settled in
because a new area is tough to buy
intelligently in
uh after six months of renting you'll
make a much better purchase on a home it
doesn't mean moving twice
and uh but you got a lot of comfort
there if you're sitting on 75 000 of
just and you owe nobody anything and you
don't have a single debt and you get
inexpensive rent and he has a good solid
job equal to what he's got now you'll
make a very calm wise purchase of your
home in florida
um or maybe it's not florida it's
alabama or it's texas or it's where it's
wherever just
breathe yeah yeah yeah so
yeah and some of this goes with um
you're holding a nine month old in your
arms and that's what i say that number i
got you know i got i got to take care of
this i got to take care of this walls
closing in on you and they're not just
just breathe get some get some friends
and i know that's hard to do where
you're at right now get some people you
can laugh with talk with turn the news
off and uh breathe
jim's in hollywood florida hey jim
what's up
hey dave john nice to have you take my
car appreciate it thank you
how can we help you
my question is uh
i'm sitting on a home right now it's
currently a hot market down here in
south florida it's worth about seven
hundred thousand dollars
i'm totally deaf great plus i own four
condos that are totally uh you know
i own them straight out and getting rent
from that you're on the house so the
house is free and clear too
correct okay
and so between the condos and social
security that my wife and i are living
off of we clear about 80 000
a year on that
my my question is i've been wanting to
move uh the last couple of years up the
line about four hours from south florida
and uh
the thing is i thought my wife feels
like she has a mandate from the from the
lord to take care of her asian
mother which is 89 years old she still
lives in the same home that she's owned
for
30 40 years now and all the siblings are
taking care of mom feeding her and
whatnot
but
my wife is a little apprehensive about
picking the move
and my thoughts were if we were to move
four hours away we can come down at
least once a week and take care of her
like you know stay on for two weeks go
back up and et cetera
and uh just want to get your thoughts on
that
i think i think is a bigger conversation
than we can do in two minutes but i
think
what care looks like and how you're
splitting that up amongst uh how she's
playing amongst her brothers and sisters
what you guys decide you're gonna do and
making sure you're both on the same page
is gonna be is gonna be important here
but yes you can live in a different
state with aging parents
yeah and you can make some trips back
absolutely um and
uh making sure that mom's taken care of
can be a mandate from the lord how it's
done
i don't think is a mandate from the lord
right
so is it done by you making some trips
down and you know working a system a
schedule with the brothers and sisters
that's okay
um
the other thing is jim it might not be
that long yeah
it might be this is just a gift you give
to your wife to just chill for a year
or maybe you sell your house and move
into one of your own condos for a year
and
there's a hundred things that could
happen right yeah but i don't know
there's nothing again i'm not going to
panic to take advantage of this real
estate market 750 000 property and
hollywood florida is not that super
expensive that's mid-market
and so um slightly above mid-market and
so you know that's a movable property in
virtually any economy
and so um you're not going to lose money
on this or miss a
narrow window of opportunity to maximize
your wealth building over this it's
you've done well you're millionaires you
got plenty of money you're you're living
fine
um it might be just a time that you're
just kind to your wife
and just this she says takes care of her
mom if you sit for a year
and you'll get mom settled you'll get
everything settled and you sell this
house for 650 000 instead of seven don't
hold that over your wife let that go man
that's just part of love it's not gonna
go down you don't have to worry about
that i'm just like man don't hold
anybody take care of your family yeah
it's just it's it's it's worth it to do
right by her
yeah that's why you did all this and you
can do right a couple hours down the
road too either one's okay but um
it's okay to just chill a little bit
john deloney good show
this is the ramsay show we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you